foreign
[Applause]
hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to dead space we're
gonna go on a little bit of a hunt we
need to go uh uh to the bridge for two
different objectives but there are two
other things that I can go to and I
think
whoa wait what
engineering here
engineering's right here
okay well I don't remember engineering
being here but maybe this is um maybe
this is one of the earlier spots that
I've been to and I just don't recognize
it being connected with this possibly
but either way if we go to engineering
we can find someone's rig and that
I don't like how that just opens
right we did go to engineering
right okay so somewhere in here
is someone's rig
track I can track it no handy that
okay good at least I can track it I just
don't remember where exactly this is
going
material gravity
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
so I'll be back once I find it or unless
something horrifying happens
with snowing this game is very like them
wow yeah
well
hello
I don't remember that did I see that
before
did I see that
I don't recall seeing that
oh
okay so somewhere in here and apparently
I don't know why my my dots were green
on that guy there
ah I needed a level three security
anyway so I can probably only find these
now that I have the level 3 security
that's good no but it's also good to
know that it's right here whoa
oh my God
don't do that don't do that to me
engineering hog chief engineer Ariel
Rousseau reporting
maintenance is
oh what was I saying I haven't flushed
right
I'm a little uh
the only thing I remember clearly is
that engine inspection are we into the
chamber and if that is the primary
engine there was
a heart
a heart the size of the room just
something
Anderson
um
almost peaceful yeah
[Music]
I can get close enough yeah
go right inside maybe where it's warm
it's dark
yeah
that makes sense oh yeah yeah that makes
a whole lot of sense
definitely don't question that at all go
right for it
all right
Lieutenant Commander Holtz rig I believe
is in Hydroponics so I'm just going to
make a quick detour to Hydroponics
now we'll be there
I believe anyway okay Hydroponics and
then there's just two more and then I've
got the master unlock and I don't know
what's in the doors with the master
unlock but it's got to be good right
It's gotta be good
maybe it's like a BFG equivalent
before we looking
Hydroponics I'm surprised I didn't see
this before but I mean if it was locked
behind a level three then I never would
have had the chance nope that blood's
still there yep all right
firing like this
oh baby
hi
[Music]
thank you
oh hi right
uh Elizabeth cross are you still in this
area or uh
no accidents
I'm sure oh God I gotta go through here
frick
oh here well not here but probably
something needs in here
I'm sure I'm not tainting these rare
specimens what was that
foreign
thought I heard the sound of one of
those things just exploding on me and a
monster crawling out of it but I was
apparently wrong
yes
I could have got I could have gone
okay I love that jungle ambiance
love that oh that level oh that's level
two did I really not go in a level two
room
wow yes please thank you
oh I missed a whole thing
I can't believe I missed the whole thing
and by thing I mean gun of course but
it's a thing too it qualifies well I
don't know what the hell that does I
don't think I've ever used that ever
been in here right
yeah it's a bit nightmarish in there
goodies
what in the fresh hell
foreign
right good
okay I picked the right floor
did that
come
I don't think I've ever been there it's
probably something good there but who
knows
entering zero gravity
huh
why we be so Dwayne
what go up but I was just oh
you're just telling me to go up but does
that mean you're just on the third floor
up here
yes it do what is over here haven't I
been here
what
what where are you going
where do you desire to take me you're
not making sense
here
not I'm so confused
I feel like this is so confused dude
fascinating do I need to like kill that
ah
oh I probably need to clear a bunch of
this I would have seen it if I would
have cleared more I bet I bet I ah yep
yep well that was easy
nothing else to it right I don't even
see a body there tell me like the body
was either in the digestion tubes or
what's the deal what is the deal with
that and why did you have me going up
I don't know let me just double check to
make sure there's no
three in here nope I don't think so
there's no room I haven't been in over
there so I'm assuming that I got
everything I'm gonna just quickly pop in
the sword and then I'm gonna fast
forward till I get to where I need to be
subsonic oscillator wow that sounds
crazy I'm gonna just put this in storage
let me sell this and I'm gonna sell this
I'm gonna use my Force gun or my contact
beam
[Music]
thank you foreign
but Overkill is uh what I'm all about
[Music]
[Applause]
okay and we go to the bridge
shockingly uh I don't know why it says I
can't go to tram control didn't it say
that there was one in in tram controller
or something like that in the tunnels or
near tram maintenance okay probably in
the tunnels means not tram maintenance
okay
let's just go to the bridge it's time
for bridge time bridge bridge yes that
was the bridge
oh my God
whoa
what
no
oh my God
I told you who told you
okay
oh thank you oh thank you for that oh
good stuff
really appreciate that that was really
lovely thank you
now arriving at the bridge yep
okay hi
Isaac a ship just shot in the USM Valor
they must have heard our SOS that fast
what's a military ship doing way out
here out on patrol whatever right now I
take a rescue from a [__] magpie
good for communications once we fix the
comms array we can get all the answers
we need
okey-dokey then
I'll go uh
fix the comms array somehow
hmm
oh I can find someone else's rig as well
well I should probably make that as my
first objective just so I don't miss it
on the way out I've been good about
finding the other ones except for the
ones in the Hydroponics
so I would hate to miss out on that
ER I'm tracking you
on the same place anyway so it probably
won't be too bad I've already done this
storage but is there any level three
lockers or nothing nothing not a thing
not a thing
huh
okay crew deck is where Hammond wend and
Hammond is currently struggling in the
vents
all right whatever I think there might
be another big Baddie over here but
we'll find out
it was up
what is up
what's up anyone guys
open I know I know you do oh boy here we
go hold on hold on hold on oh that's not
what I was hoping for
okay well there goes my kaboomies all
right whatever
I'll take it
how are you what oh my God you came out
of nowhere
hey right get contacted you get
contacted
man I really picked the wrong weapon for
this encounter
why oh no
oh my God
I'm eating
oh wow this is inconvenient okay hold on
hold on hold on
YouTube wham bam thank you everybody you
one more
we done
we all done
huh anybody else
man I could have done that a lot better
if I didn't have my big old wompy bumpy
uh-huh
okay
another one I'm getting weird feedback
spikes on local comms whatever's wrong
with the comms array is spreading no
that's not it
so um the daughter communication should
be open
you can head down to the comps control
station
and Isaac
watch what you say
I think someone's listening in
uh-huh okay
so where was oh oh wait a minute I
remember I do remember
comes
yeah
okay
floor three please
yeah
that could have gone a lot better if I'd
have cut off the bombs and then used the
bombs but I was too busy blasting and I
lasered for some reason instead of wall
boomping um but it seemed like the good
idea against those dudes it all went
horribly wrong I could I'm I'm big
enough to admit that it went horribly
wrong and I did terribly
and I admit that therefore I absolve
myself of any responsibility for that
why is this not opening it was behind me
[__]
that's fine
Peek-a-boo I see you
ah that looks terrible
was that like that before I don't know
yippee
wahoo
yippie
[Music]
I feel like that wasn't like that before
I think I see you dude
anything in storage
ah good this is nice
that is very nice I like this
okay okay
wait is this like a safe spot for me to
shoot this dude
hey can you uh shut up
why am I not using this
oh that was convenient oh there's two of
yous well good thing I got plenty of
these
thank you clearance Clarence thank you
Clarence this
how are you not dead because I didn't
let your tentacles grow and that's where
the real damage comes in
do it
oh no he's exploded
foreign
[Music]
that was much nicer glad I went in this
room
yay
how much ammo did I chew up a lot oh
there was an explodey right here well
that's okay
did you guys drop anything good
why do you never drop anything oh you
dropped the pulse rounds great
just what I wanted
plasma oh boy Whoa there's another one
die
okay all done though is there anything
in the break room I don't think there
was but just in case
just some coffee that I apparently can't
have
I wouldn't be surprised if the coffee
had tentacles they'd be perfectly honest
I wouldn't be surprised
all that just gets twisted into a
horrible amalgamation of goo
and not the kind of coffee goo that you
like
hello
hey that's a level three
columns control room huh
well hold on hold on hold on we got some
goodies
ah thank you clearance
perfect perfect excellent excellent
good excellent I think it's about time
to switch back to uh Ye Old Faithful
what is being blockaded over here what
could possibly be blockaded and why is
this locked
[Music]
hello
saving I like saving
time
good to know where and ah interesting
fascinating is that a fat stuff
french fry someone hotwired the dishes
together and blew up the system
screwed no it was sloppy work
some of the dishes are intact if I
replace them and create a new circuit
with no gaps we could broadcast a signal
short range only but it should work
okay do it
I'll uh
keep an eye on things here okay you do
that you've been so helpful at whatever
you've been doing
uh ye Bailey
e Bailey
Communications log first comms operator
Bailey reporting I want this on record
the ship is under attack but Captain
Matthias has refused to issue a
distressed call and we all know why this
whole operation is illegal ages 7 was
sealed off they knew it we knew it and
we all kept our mouths shut that ends
now mayday mayday mayday this is USG is
wait what the hell
Jesus he took the whole cons away
offline
it's over it's over man if you just
thought about it you could have done it
yourself you could have fixed this
you could have fixed it
thank you Clarence what is this
hello progress support Captain Benjamin
Matthias to Paragon Jordan Una
be my last transmission afterwards I'll
make sure our pilgrimage can be
completed without interference
we have successfully brought the holy
marker on board
Dr kind an expert on the original marker
is deciphering its secrets
forget me for quarantining you just
seven
director eckhart's work may have been
inconvenienced but
they're suffering some sort of epidemic
regardless Planet crack begins tomorrow
on schedule
see so you can scratch out its illegal
operation now that the true prize is
ours
here's gonna try to cover this up
Altman be praised
with I saw
very fun very cool nice hand thing you
dude
um but you're dead now so uh if you'll
be doing that in the great beyond
whatever unit I mean the great
togetherness the unit unity in the great
Unity is that it am I guessing that
correctly I've read the book and I I
don't even remember
all right what do we got here hey wait a
minute
I see you over there are you dead
already what whoa that is that a good
one or a bad one well oh man this is
this
starting immediately now
where'd you go there you are
and you're dead somehow
come to me whoa who did that who's
ambitious
all right we're going
we're going zero g combat here where'd
you go
where heard that there you are
show your whoa whatevers
come on come on don't be shy come on
come on come on
oh wow that's
what are you scared
you scared
Oh no you're afraid
come on do some
do some
oh this is just sad don't give me any
attitude
you're gonna get this floaty bit of
nothing
you are you all right there I guess
we're done now all right let's pull out
the bad ones first
let's see yoink uh oh
Lucas come on you want to kiss and there
oh another one
where
foreign
like the red eyes staring at me
thank you thank you that's a bad one
bad one
cause we got good ones so what we need
to do is get it back up and going in a
way that allows us to connect it from
that blueness all the way up
and through this I also had one over
there by the entrance that I pulled
accidentally which is a straight line
okay so I'm gonna use my big brain and
we're gonna get this easy peasy no
problem
foreign
could you hurry up
there you go here
that one
but let's put you here
we go
I think this one should go there because
I believe it's a horizontal not a
vertical they are specific
another nope not that one this one nope
not that one this one
are you over there
and then last one
there you are perfect
easy peasy
okey-dokey then
good where is it I think you got it try
opening the channel to The Valor okay
I'm sure I'm just in time that
definitely didn't take way too long
no way at all
everything is fine we're online I'm
Gonna Save
peekaboo
I see you
USM valve broadcasting on all
frequencies to USG ishimura in response
to your SOS
we picked up your Escape pod number 47
and are on route to your position this
message will repeat every 30 seconds
until you respond
oh no
Escape pod oh [__] the Pod Hammond
jettisoned
that creature was inside no no no no no
you must send Valor come in
come in Valor
her signal isn't strong enough can we
deploy the long range antenna no
something's blocking the blast doors
over the comps array the hell
it'll be a manual release over
maintenance I'll go keep trying to reach
them
I'll go I know you were just trying to
volunteer but I'll go don't worry I'll
go
I know you're gonna fight me over this
one but I'll do it I'm going and that's
that oh
thank you
I take one of these
I bought one of these how about one of
this looks big and heavy
okay well this seems ridiculous ah you
just fell over and died I wished a
bullet over nothing
hello thank you for the node
oh
what am I looking at this is just the
tiniest down ever
okay
lots of Whispers
oh oh oh my God oh my God okay
oh my God wait no what is that what was
that what was that give give give that
tip go I had it I had it I gotta go back
for it
I gotta go back
I gotta go back who's there I saw it I
had it come on come on come on I had it
it was
why was it on the ground that time
you son of a [__] right I gotta go back
for it I gotta go back this time I got
it here we go
I'm gonna miss I'm not gonna miss him
not gonna miss him I saw it I saw it I
saw it was there no there no there who's
there how did I miss it what
what how did I miss it it's only visible
from this angle that must have been it
it's only visible from this angle I
gotta go hold on everybody hold on I got
this
was it where was it I saw it I saw it I
saw it I saw it I saw him come on where
was it how can it be gone
400 sweet creditses
mine oh that was so incredibly worth it
I'm really glad I did that
do you think there was anything down
that weird tunnel that I saw
probably not probably not probably not
well that's worth something
we'll go down
text log it happened again third time in
the last however long it's been I came
in after shift and found bro so at the
transmitter again they looked like hell
I don't know if they'd even slept since
the last time I caught them in here not
very reassuring to see the chief
engineer in that state Rousseau didn't
hear me come in so this time I just
listened they were talking to the relay
crew again talking then listening they
even laughed God how long has it been
since anyone on this [__] ship left I
know I should say something to
engineering I've already told her so
over and over that we don't have a comms
relay crew that the array is broken
Beyond repair that no one is coming to
save us and they listen but it's like
they can't keep those thoughts in their
head as if it's too much I get it
everything on this ship is too much so
this time I just let them talk if a
broken transmitter and a mic full of
static gives them something to hold on
to maybe even helps them keep this ship
running a little longer who am I to
judge and yeah maybe I've talked into
the same transmitter myself once or
twice after hours just in case like that
poem says hope sings a tune without the
words never stops hello
I know I'm not familiar with that one
um let me save first because I like it
and then let's try bench
I mean I got five dying
dying
uh there's really no more damage that I
could do and really damage well well
that's not too far off all right I'll do
that it's pretty far to that one and I
don't need the fire I mean it is more
damage but I can't reach it anyway so
I'll get that on the next one all right
off we go
to the comms array
you okay
y'all right there
you're a little sick you oh my God oh my
God oh my God
ah I forgot
[Music]
[Applause]
well that was awful
that was awful
I hated everything about that
screw you oh baby
oh baby
oh baby oh baby
oh baby okay cool
that's what I like to see
I love that oh my God I love that okay
so I have that I can buy more notes
cause I'm gonna need them
I'll buy two more whatever I got a lot
of money and there's a bench right
outside I can upgrade my plasma cutter
and I could be very very very very very
very very very very very very happy as
opposed to what I just experienced which
was not happiness I'm not sure what
emotion I had
but it wasn't happiness I can assure you
that what do we got
and a new power node
oh what do we got what are we got melee
attacks can knock enemies prone I become
stronger I like that
I like that a lot
oh
you mean I can whap him Bap them way
harder
I love that
I love that I love that a lot but I
don't like can you know can is um
Ken is ambitious I'd rather it be like
will but can I'll take can can is good
all right let's see if we can solve this
problem
oh
I'll knock you prone I'll do it yeah get
ready I'm Gonna Knock You prone
yeah oh shoot get thrown
yes
you dead you oh I'm sorry you dead oh no
oh it's such a damn shame for you oh you
got knocked prone
oh it's such a shame well but you got
sucked into the ether as well oh wow
damn shame
got sucked into the prone Zone that's
really truly unfortunate for you and I
really truly do not care
what's a grumbly grooney what's a
squishy
one moment please
there's a lot of goodies this is a lot
of goodies this is this is a lot of
goodies
what's in here why does it tell me maybe
I should go in here first you know I got
a funny feeling um
funny feeling maybe I should say because
I I just
like it
shaving's important
uh-huh interesting
foreign
it's not coming off without a fight
Isaac there's no time there is if I use
the ads cannons manual targeting like
before I can shoot it right off the hole
I got this you focus on the Valor will
do that is so much confidence
dot I don't know why I've got so much
confidence about that I guess I did kick
its ass before it's not like it's gonna
be any different this time
all right big guy come here you
tickle
all right
Gucci Gucci goo
all right get ready for a whole lot of
me
uh round two huh
that looks like you were about to get me
but you definitely didn't
foreign
get ready for manual targeting
all right gotta call in a strike
I don't know what this is but it looks
like I should shoot it oh yeah oh yeah
oh God that's not good good please don't
oh God hello oh hey
destroyed well I feel like you shouldn't
have done that that was rude oh God
doing they just
they just rang Bang
probably trying to ring bangle me if
we're imperfectly honest okay
[Music]
whoa that was cool whoa
amazing
all right all right all right all right
so what am I looking at oh my God
it's mines
how is this minefield
oh my God okay
holy crap okay okay you're not joking
around are you oh I saw that thankfully
I saw it oh
oh my God I see it no I don't see it no
I don't all right wait a minute I wasn't
even done
can I shoot these at you
oh God I pulled that right to me well
that was a bad idea
oh wait air air is important
oh my God don't get don't don't move
turns out I ran out of a area to go over
on the right
I'll try the antenna's manual release
again do it
I've got a transmission loaded and ready
to go
not digging any risks oh oh God where
are you going buddy
you think there was any goodies out
there
oh I did have health
oh okay
all right there might have been some
goodies out here let me just take a
quick peek
bye I won't let me go
well to be perfectly honest uh I also
would not want to go out there because
uh it's terrifying the thought of just
drifting out alone in space is awful and
I would never want to experience it um
ever in the history of ever
quickly look to see if there's not like
a
uh nope can't get there so uh no good
for me
good stuff good stuff good stuff
all right take two on that one
Wham ah
now that's some comms
finally USM Valor this is Kendra Daniels
on the USG ishimura do not open the
Escape pod repeat do not open that
escape pod do you read
[Applause]
thank you
all right well man I I stood there and
took that like a champ
I was freaking ready what happened
something shook the whole crew deck what
hit it asteroid some things got onto the
Valor a rescue ship
they found your Escape pod and the one
that used to be Chen God damn it the
Valor scrap by the time another ship
here's SOS Beacon well I'll be done no
that's what I was telling you I found an
executive shuttle on the crew deck
intact and the log says that shuttle's
missing at Singularity core it can't get
us home wait maybe I can't
if the Valor Singularity core is okay I
could Salvage it install it on that
shuttle we're [__] out of here
where's the Valor now it's near cons
keep us stable Isaac I'll grab a suit
and Eva onto the Valor meet me there
we'll find that core together let's see
if he clean up their own mess I'm saving
what I can
okay well that's a lot of really
decisive action for all of a sudden
having a ship crashing to us but I look
forward to working together
yippee Teamwork Makes a Dream Work
foreign
[Music]
store
okay I'm don't need this
I'm good on ammo actually I'm not good
on health but I always imagine that I'm
gonna pick that up
that always gives me when I need it
probably maybe a little bit maybe just a
little bit maybe
okay one last Gandhi ride
I'm not gonna miss anything this time
I'm gonna look straight off to the right
I didn't see anything
okay wow the tubas really got into that
ride we they said you dead
better be dead I don't like it when
there's a body you should have dissolved
you should have disintegrated long long
ago
I don't think so I don't think so I
ain't about that
I'm not about that wait what
did I miss it how did I miss it
what do you mean over here what do you
mean over here
what what do you one more time what
one more time everybody
you think they'll greet me as one of
their own with this sweet pulse rifle
where where was it then oh well wait no
that's where I came from
what
does anybody else confused how did I
miss this
was I supposed to just go outside
okay I'm done uh lyxian please make it
seem like I'm not horrifically dumb
sensors crashed in outside I really
wouldn't be inside the ship yeah
okay so actually I hope you're making me
look real smart right now
all right
hey wait is that a Valor
it's not one of them valor's
anybody
anything in any of these alcoves I feel
like this would be almost the perfect
place for a really cool secret of some
kind
some kind of specialness
a few circuit boards that got blasted
into the space
the space I'm not seeing any fine Isaac
I'm on board the battle is trashed but I
can make it to the bridge
the hell was that what do you what do
you think it was what do you do you
really need to think what it was at this
point
[Music]
oh
well
for this episode
thank you
and as always
I will see you
in the next video on The Valor bye-bye